I watched the first season of your
program and was just completely blown
away it's such a good show and the
creator of the show is Byron Belasco he
seems to know this world so well the
writing is so sharp you guys play MMA
fighters and you really feel like
everything is completely 100% truthful
and it's a it's a show that can be
brutal it can be sexy you can be funny
but man it's a good show
boy we're putting you on the PR yeah
fees on our show it's gonna be fun I
really appreciate it yeah you had to
really dedicate yourself as an actor
because you weren't in fighting shape
when you got this role is that right
well I mean you know there's fighting
shape and then there's walking into a
cage where you're looking at another man
who's about who's looking to do nothing
but take your head off so yeah I was in
some fighting shape but in no way shape
or form was I ready for this job but
this is what the shape you got into for
the role of the show I no longer look
like that I mean you know you've got me
you don't know help people that you know
you can just say oh yeah yeah under I
got under here you how much do you weigh
right now I am a hundred and seventy two
pounds on the dot okay hundred seventy
two pounds I'm told that you can
deadlift 405 pounds that's true it's
unbelievable to me
well for and for all the all the
meatheads that I follow an Instagram or
other social media what I like to put
out there and this is course is coming
from a kid who grew up in Boston you
know probably weighed 110 pounds up
until just recently is that the four or
five pounds of course was lifted when I
was a hundred and forty pounds which is
something like 2.6 percent of my body
weight which I was very diligent in
making sure I did the math correctly
because you know when you can do a
physical feat and you want to make sure
you get the numbers right sure and and
this is not what I've been known for you
know nothing known for deadlift before
or right guys want to make sure I get it
you're like mom you can lift many times
your own weight you know what I'm
talking about
I don't know what you're talking about
you dropped 30 pounds at one point in
the show your character needed to drop
30 pounds to make weight and so you
demand you decided or were asked to also
drop 30 pounds pretty quickly I'm
curious what were you like what was your
yeah you come home it's like you're my
beautiful wife says she they you know
the house looks beautiful she's worked
really hard you know her job the dog
looks great I come in there and I'm like
I'm just beside myself with hunger and
anger and retribution against who knows
an imaginary figure and she's like are
you hungry I'm like a hungry of course
I'm hungry I'm starved I'm actually I'm
literally starving I have not yet even
800 calories am i hungry yes among do
you want to go out to dinner yeah you
know if I decide I want to go to dinner
we're gonna go up to there because I'm
the one who's cutting weight she said
wherever you want to go of course
wherever I want to go I'm the one who
hasn't eaten I haven't eaten anything
right no you can understand
I was not not to plum I have a very a
very accepting it sounds like yeah you
just needed to have a giant steak
sandwich and french fries and then just
shut seriously that's like yeah
you